it's kyle hendricks here this afternoon
on the hill for chicago yeah he has been
a rough customer against the brewers
making start number 24 career against
milwaukee
nine and six his record at 284 earned
run average outstanding a year ago
against the brewers
he was 1-0
a 1.08 earned run average pretty good
season for him a year ago 6-5 record in
12 starts so yes
11 decisions in 12 starts and a 288
earned red average
and we're set to go here lorenzo kane
against hendricks
and takes a swing at that first pitch
little tapper to bryant
and there's quickly one out
here's kesten hero and a 3-2
swaying at a mass he went upstairs and
got him swinging
a good battle ultimately won by
hendricks moved the ball all around the
strike zone and went back to that
elevated fastball that we talked about
something he never did when he first
came into the league or you know never
did intentionally
two away here's yelich
first pitch into lafiel the base hit
good start for
yelich's
go
the first strike is going to be the best
one to hit
that was actually off the outside corner
yeah but christian looking for it
hendricks likes to work away he doesn't
come in for strikes all that often
they get a fastball up out away from him
and he goes right with it two on and two
out for shaw wind blowing out slightly
towards left
hendricks delivers swaying in a fly ball
hit into shallow left it won't even get
out towards the left as baez is there
and makes the catch
and that ends the inning had shaw out on
his front foot popped it up
facing brendan woodruff making his
second start of the young season and no
decision on opening day here in
milwaukee against minnesota four inning
six hits
three runs he used 78 pitches to get
through those four innings
brewers would win that game in extras
and he strikes out to start the game
that's a nice pitch couple of fastballs
then got him
yeah with the bender
heck of a pitch by
brandon woodruff rizzo oh for eight in
the series
here comes the 2-1 bouncing ball toward
first glove by hira he'll take it to the
bag and that's the end of the inning
cubs go one two three
we go to inning number two cubs nothing
milwaukee nothing this 0-0 ball game
as we go to the bottom of the third
inning at seven eight nine do up for the
cubs hayward walters and hendricks
hayward leaves off first pitch gets past
terra
and woodruff there late throw a little
off target
by robertson
defensive play there did not work out in
milwaukee's favor
plenty hop but robert senzair
just not able to get a good throw off
tony walters just picked up by the
chicago cubs
the pitch ground ball to second
robertson will field thr and tag and
then throw to first in time it's a 4-3
double play
robertson was right near hayward as he
fielded it so he reached out and tagged
him and had plenty of time to set his
feet and then throw to first nice play
by robertson after the air to come back
and get both outs anyway
woodruff looking into his catcher manny
pina
and the pitch and he gives him a
fastball in 97 hendricks had no
intention of swinging the bat he takes
it for strike three
that is the third strikeout for woodruff
and he faces the minimum in the third in
the unconventional way after the error
christian ellis facing hendricks here to
open up the fourth
yelish
with a change up into left center long
run for peterson and happens going to
fall between them big turn it first and
yell it slides in there to second with a
double he gets that extra base hit and
the brewers in business here in the top
of the fourth
still scoreless game yelich led off the
inning with a double and he's still at
second with two down liner torch short
caught by baez inning over good job by
hendricks it's not easy to give up a
leadoff double and walk away
unscored upon but that's what he's doing
rumors don't score we go to the bottom
of the fourth two down now for anthony
rizzo
one two swing and a miss
nasty breaking ball down in on that back
foot of rizzo and he slams his helmet
down
in disgust
another one two three for brandon
woodruff he is dealing folks
brendan woodruff to start the fifth
inning now out on the mound is not
allowed to hit only one base runner so
far and has been very efficient through
four and inks 35 pitches 2-2 on the way
called strike three got that fast ball
in the outer edge six strikeouts now for
woodruff that's nasty right on the edge
for seymour
right on the outside corner woodruff had
to work a little bit in the fourth
inning through ten pitches only the
second time in this game he's throwing
double digit pitches in an inning still
on two on buy as woodruff throws
struck him out swinging gassed him up
with 98
woodruff clean through five
we head to the sixth at wrigley a ball
and two strikes on louise
hendricks about ready to throw pitch
number 85 in the game so now second and
third ureas the one two swinging in a
miss struck him out
kyle gets out of the jam and it stays a
scoreless game
outstanding work by the professor one
down for tony walters the catcher
and this one hit the opposite way yellow
makes the catch
sliding out in left field for out number
two
nice play christian yelich got a great
jump on that humpback line drive takes a
potential knock away from walters and
brandon woodruff looks out to christian
says thanks pal five and two thirds in
the well one ball and two strikes nobody
on base
here's the pitch from woodruff
ground ball first base kira's got it
steps on the bag it's six no hit innings
from brandon woodruff see if the third
time through is the charm for the cubs
here this afternoon indeed ian happel
for two he is struck out swinging in
line to left
3-1 pitch ground ball through the right
side and under the glove of robertson
and into right field for a base hit and
that's the first hit of the game allowed
by brandon woodruff what a run up until
now by the brewer ace eight strikeouts
on the afternoon for woodruff
the 3-2
fly ball right field racing in as garcia
still racing in garcia dives and makes a
sliding catch to in the inning a fist
pump from woodruff as he walks off the
mound and the brewers get out of the
seven here's lorenzo kane to lead off
the eighth inning this pitch high deep
drive left field peterson back kane out
onto waveland
breaks the scoreless tie
it's one nothing brewers on lorenzo
kane's first home run of the season
up and in and lorenzo with a back footed
out of here with that wind the waves
blowing out to left let's see if the
cubs can answer right back john peterson
will lead it off
[Applause]
this had the sound
right
the ball comes off the bat down and then
heater and he knew it the second he hit
it three quarters of the way up to
bleachers
tie game
one-on-one on kane
workman's pitch
and kane drives this one out to center
field back on a tap at the track it is
gone
lorenzo kane with a three-run blast his
second homer of the game
and the brewers lead it four to one
lean back on him low there's jason
hayward with two down here it comes
swinging a line drive right center field
that's a base hit
chris bryant comes in to score it's four
to two
the cubs are still alive
they're all loaded up
broke up the no hitter with a solid
single in the seventh
box burger looks in here's the 2-2 pitch
popped him up
left side yelich coming in he's
underneath of it and the brewers win in
10. brad boxberger comes in and slams
the door shut